[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody I'm chassis with me is our
new Pokemon expert Callie plaguey hello
she's a new associate editor here over
at gamespot and this is our very first
live stream up 2017 really excited we're
starting it off with a classic we're
playing pokemon snap on the Virtual
Console on Wii U yeah it just came out
today in ten dollars and so we just had
yes because we love this game we've all
this game you love to selfie we have it
all so we're hanging out over on twitch
on youtube so please hang out with us
ask those questions about Pokemon Callie
knows everything there is to know about
pokemon pretty much it's yeah yeah a lot
she loved it she loves it yeah and
inverted so we're uh we're jumping right
into this and taking good pictures right
now is it still training this is yeah
this is a tutorial so as soon as we
gather changing via who look access but
yeah so we're just in the beach if you
photos a Pokemon send back to Professor
Oak so on a place called Pokemon island
island professor pocas semanas here
because we're
famed photographer actual person is
called podsnap so yeah we named her
Britney yeah she's ruby's just decided
getting cool shots oh uh nothing
particularly good i say some piggies you
know to give you some background this
game came out for the nintendo 64 and
stuff so do you have vivid memories of
playing this absolutely I was on my n64
Hurley all the time like legitly all I
love the n64 oh yeah which pictures well
now I forget how to do this okay I have
this cool picture good job on the pigeon
yeah this is the one I decided to show
piggies picture what else do we got
there's a doduo in the distance with
butter free Alex it's probably like this
solid meows picture of you ah monster
dude I didn't know doe do it was that
big hmm like the the scaling and this
game is really interesting to me oh this
looks like a disaster let's keep that
one okay great to Professor up alright
so yeah there's been a lot of Pokemon
lately so I mean I've been playing a lot
of Pokemon selling you were playing
pokemon moon I have yeah I have a
hundred and forty hours already Wow
which is a lot more than i do but it's
been some time until I plane over
vacation I'm still I just did the trial
with a volcano and no water and the
jungle marowak dancing love it
I let me see this Joe do oh yeah besides
00 30 points how's the pose I think it's
a solid pose I think he's your pokemon
isn't in the middle of the frame look
look I was on rail look I was walking
around right car really tough clearly
I've been played this game it was if you
don't know it was on wii virtual console
um but if you want to do that you have
to use the Wii Menu app and it's kind of
Yeah right oh oh that's my favorite
picture so far it's it's really
beautiful it's a beautiful disaster it
is a beautiful disaster we're over on
YouTube and twitch right now hanging out
with you guys so we're gonna take your
questions so please talk to us about
Pokemon tell us what your favorite
pokemon episode is tell us who your
favorite Pokemon is we don't have why I
have a favorite cali does not have a
favorite I I have a new favorite do you
tell me who your favorite Pokemon my new
favorite Pokemon is mimic you love me
you're gonna make You plush on your desk
and I do super jealous oh yeah you can
save my progress yeah I I would like to
keep going but I would really love to
change the invert okay no now go back
you know what I'm just gonna do this
we're playing pokemon snap its kind of
inverted but we're gonna make do with it
and make it work yeah yeah but yeah so I
have been breeding pokemon uber
competitive team in my Oh tutorial time
ago here's the tutorial so you're on
these rails and you're going around
Pokemon island so this pokemon is this
Pokemon island is pretty much not
bothered by people except for this rail
here is some reason yes I couldn't
Raylan and then front left uh yeah and
it's supposed to be like totally
inhabited by Pony I'm mm-hmm and oh they
see I thought about that what would you
forget that the pokeball highlights
today center and also he gives you
something to give to the Pokemon to get
better pictures right so they're like
apples yeah and there's like some kind
of offer to you there's some kind of a
specific ball that you can throw I think
yes if memory serves um the cool thing
is it's kind of funny that they decided
to bring this to Wii U console least in
North America it's been in Japan and
Europe for a while now yeah but in sun
and moon there's this camera like a
photo taking mini game of sorts where
you do a similar thing except you get
likes and comments so it's like the 2016
version of this and i just thought that
was clever to release a game in the you
know the 20 20 year anniversary of
pokemon didn't have this kind of beloved
weird oh look at that mouse chasing that
bird you oh wait he's a cat he's gonna
eat him oh yeah that's scary let's say
let's hi to people on twitch and youtube
let's see Bob Jones says hey oh hello
yes we are playing pokemon snap and this
is cali if you have not met callie
before she is brand-new here this is
very first stream this is your first
time on camera cooing sputterin is my
god first appearance and i'm very
excited yes we're very excited to have
you miss a day three mice day three yeah
I'm fine coincidentally my first stream
was also from when I was a demo for
Pokemon Sun and Moon and that was on my
second day so yeah yeah very similar to
do it that is how we do it yeah okay
there's anything else up there before
there was where the poblano up good
shots of it early so cute okay I'm gonna
move over to youtube and see what's
going on in here this does not control
uh so I did ask what is your favorite
pokemon episode and Kyle Splinter one
said best pokemon episode was when
charmander's flame almost went out and
died that episode still makes me sad I
guess I cry emotional I cried the first
time I saw that episode and I still get
really sad how could you do that out of
him he just stayed there he just waited
for his master he didn't want to go with
anyone he was so loyal like that episode
oil
futurama which one uh Jurassic Park oh
it's like he just waits forever okay
that's a good picture oh you're like I
soil Pokemon seven pictures that's been
said why are you guys playing this
because it came out today on Wii U it's
on Virtual Console today and you can get
it for 10 bucks if you so desire and
want to take pictures of Pokemon that's
why we're playing it today yeah also cuz
we love Pokemon we just wanted to play
pokemon we just love and we're ready
look at her shirts worse if you have to
we are very I love pizza keji but what
few is better than one yeah actually is
it know that that's solid Pidgey but
photo that's the one you want to go with
this is a weird one yeah I don't like
that one so can we get things to throw
at them to get them to look at us or not
yet oh is it too early on it's too early
hmm gotcha it's been obviously years
yeah yeah these are the photos so back
on the Virtual Console for we when this
came out which was I think 2007 the you
had the ability to send pictures in the
game to the wii message board and so
back in the day there was no we message
board on n64 so what you had to do is
take him to like a blockbuster and i get
him printed out which was super awesome
yeah I totally did that your print
anything was like Game Boy camera I
can't double this I think this is a job
I think that's a beautiful photo look at
that butter I didn't bring it Oh bye bye
butterfree also a solid episome I God
goodness I'll talk about crying that
yeah what episode of Pokemon made you
cry the most let's let us know on
YouTube and switch so far it's the ones
that i just mentioned bye bye butterfree
and the one about Charmander on the rock
and he almost died I was very sad about
it I mean even the first episode I
choose you pikachu is
is just instantly I was like this is my
favorite show yes my favorite thing in
the whole world I love it yeah did you
start with red or blue oh this is a fun
fact about me huh I started with the
cards and then I watched the show and
then interest I didn't play the games
until crystal came out because as a
child I refused to play pokemon until I
kalia the girl Wow and then I went back
and I bought red blue and yellow and
played through all of them because I
just have us there good so obsessed but
so good as you've played every single
pokemon game yes um I own both or like
all three versions up through gen3 at
our gen 4 yeah and then um yeah and then
I stopped spending that much money on
them because I had other things got it
over in YouTube a man named mark medina
said he feels like he's seen these girls
before Oh mark hi mark hi everyone okay
Oh see let's see if anyone else has any
thoughts on pokemon episodes okay so we
have a comment about lowland Pokemon so
the heart text said I'm loving a lowland
muck / Grimer I caught one early on in
my son play through and he's been
kicking ass the whole way through I
won't oh my god I love a lowland remeron
buck it's poison dark if i remember
correctly and I so when I went to
preview Pokemon Sun and Moon I wasn't a
lot to talk about it because it wasn't
yet announced and I was so bummed
because I wanted to tell every was like
it's so cool it's rainbow and I just
loved it how do i unlock more courses
try to see more points yeah good let's
try to obtain more points I know so much
about Pokemon I've forgotten so much is
this game is sold its it's from 1999 it
was like we baby yeah you were a wee
baby it's like all the way back when
like Ricky Martin was a thing
Dawson's Creek yeah it was you know
before y2k yeah it was the year that
Backstreet Boys his millennium came out
a lot of things yeah that's a really
good year for pop music but yeah yeah
nice and I 9 was a very good brand for
you yeah I just brought it up cuz no one
asked me I just like 1999 uh let's see
anyone else have thoughts on their
favorite pokemon episodes tell us on
YouTube and twitch what is your favorite
pokemon game oh I've been off regular
game whatever you want well pokemon
stadium oh I need ya at the wake you up
i forgot pokemon stadium was my favorite
oh yeah and then um just in general
which pokemon game is my favorite I
liked yellow a lot I yellow I hold close
to my heart for some reason I think it
was just the time in my life probably
and I was just like peak Pokemon yeah at
that time I liked why a lot in terms of
more recent games yeah why was fun I'm
enjoying sun right now but I thought
that it was kind of very much too easy
or too much training up off the top that
frustrated me just because I want to get
right into the game I would have liked
to just been able to just jump in and
like hey are you familiar with Pokemon
alright jump in but instead it's like
you walk around it's just like all you
walked so far let's heal your Pokemon
for you I'm just like dude give me a
little bit of a job right yeah I am I
didn't have that that problem I think
because I was reviewing it at the time I
had to so cute I had to go through it
pretty quickly so i didn't have the same
the same problems that a lot of people
did where they said the opening was
really slow and cinnamon but i think
that is probably the best pokemon game
has ever been made my personal favorite
is crystal or remote bold is because you
started with it yeah i have you hold a
close to your heart that attachment to
it that's how i feel about yellow yeah i
mean i love yellow i loved having
pikachu up behind me and all
yeah it's just the best but yeah I mean
I really I think sun and moon really do
a lot of positive things for the game in
terms of just a regular playthrough and
also for the metagame in competitive so
totally speaking of competitive still
hdz 17 / on youtube said tell us about
your competitive team oh here we go okay
so they're all about it I always like to
like / breed so I breed more Pokemon
than I really need a head of time that's
good because I need someone to Trey
different yeah I have plenty so I've
been breeding umbreon espeon I have a
Jolteon a Vaporeon but those are really
for going through the battle tree and
then in addition to that i am going to
use toxic pecs I can't decide whether I
want to use merciless to regenerator as
an ability on it but I have access to
both and then oh sure uh and what else
Lowen marowak mom I guys I didn't get
the proper type of cocoa so I'll
probably use t'appeler legs Oh for my
top ooh and probably sell a stila but I
haven't decided yet got it yeah nice
awesome let's see what's going over on
twitch we're on twitch in you too right
now what's up I'll check out this doduo
that its job I love it it's me that's me
that's me that's me as a dodo anyway so
Ron you're super cute even twitch let's
see what's going on over unto which cuz
I've been neglecting them I'm so sorry
guys hang out with us and talk about
pokemon with us tell me what your
favorite pokemon game was and tell me
about what your favorite thing in 1999
was besides pokemons someone's did a
shout out to the faculty which is a
great movie have you seen that movie I'm
not seeing them yeah someone shouted
that out on youtube that is a good 1999
nerds good job good job let's see uh
oops you ride what's up he said surprise
you guys even have a wii u in the office
till uh yeah gadget one thanks edge i
have wanted
house I do too it's an astute kids oh my
as I just moved oh yeah I just haven't
taken it out because I've only been
playing like my ps4 and my pc gaming
console pc gaming on laptop and my xbox
one but actually i'm not using my xbox
that much i use it for pet bookings xbox
all the time yeah yeah let's see um hi
Callie from Joey hi Joey I drew
youngster joey youngster joey wants to
battle top percentage of Rattata we got
it I thought there was a question it was
just a whole 00 d mu girl 2000 asa don't
forget the app or ash left Pikachu in
the forest with the wild Pikachu oh yeah
yes man my heart my heart when do I yes
okay the tunnel all right we got a new
level so if you're just tuning in we're
playing pokemon snap on the wii u
virtual console it's out today if you
want to get it that's us we named our
photographer Brittany but the real
characters name is tough next he turn
around can you like 360 my Pikachu it I
could but I'm really focused their guess
that electabuzz get that boy oh oh oh
that would have been good i forgot i
forgotten everything i'm sure i'd to be
fair i was literally like seven when
this came not even I you missed the
kikuna I did I've he'll come back I'm
ruining he might come back there he's
back guess he's back its cocoon oh oh
yes who's back again speaking come
Eminem was also hot in 1985 throwbacks
hmm wonder if I can uh oh wait that
electabuzz was yeah gooshie ride also
said the row back I remember picking us
up at blockbuster to after waiting weeks
for a copy yeah I think I rented this a
few times at blockbuster before I
actually owned it I probably should just
bought it right off the back it's
supposed to be ghastly what is this
yeah dude i think so that's just a
floating ball that's ghastly mysterious
oh I forgot how reward Magikarp I have
played an on-rails doing like this in a
million years so Michael for this stream
there's another Pikachu Oh piglet my
goal for this dream is to find my son up
Psyduck I just really wanted to find him
because he is my beloved son loves I
love him so much Oh who's your favorite
Jen one my favorite Jen one is Evie no
good choice good good choice this guy's
trying to break in d mu girl said that
silver was the favorite and I loved gale
of darkness on gamecube Oh Caleb Dirk I
I own gale of darkness I don't think I'd
played much I didn't play that at all I
had um XD and colosseum Mel mm-hmm which
shows you how much I love polka ya
question from gaming hobo does the game
use motion controls no nope it controls
the same way you would use the pro
controller or if you have it on we the
omen the UH the classic controller but
uh the nice thing about the wii u
version is that you can use the pro
controller which of course you don't
have access to in the hwy app that we
load at and then um dude does it not
have enough oh there it is I was like
Rory rise so we r DN Magnemite no rules
oh wow he's drunk I partied way too hard
party hard party hard alright let's see
what's going on yeah yeah that's us
partying all the time with Pokemon since
1990 we're partying like it's not today
yeah we are partying like it's 19
million is a horrible picture don't even
turn that one in so is she now use it
you did a fine job a fine job RJ 816
said welcome to gamespot cali you're a
really talented editor
I agree you are so talented I'm very
silent you're here that is so sweet oh
it's Haunter duh oh hey hunter yep d mu
girl was right said I think it's hunter
you get the pics when you get the pic
and should show it you're right you were
right clearly I was a small baby ya see
one has so many pokemon I'm just gonna
do it just for that yeah I was saying
before that I would love a new version
of this in VR oh my god that would be
incredible that's why that's why
upgraded version of wanting it for wii u
cuz i was always like oh it'd be so cool
to be able to move the gamepad around
and obviously that's not happening
mm-hmm but yeah vr is the next step we
can't have it for wii u ya know just
pokemon snap for vr just makes sense to
me like a new one and then we could get
new her pokemon up in there you know she
us what pokemon to be real yeah when i
was around 10 years old i told my mom I
wanted to be a genetic engineer so I can
make pokemon real oh I got into call
that's amazing oh my god that's
dedication love it obviously I love it
the video game passion won out over the
chemistry passion but yeah well Pokemon
his life hook up on his love Pokemon his
life we're hanging out over on YouTube
and twitch so please hang out with us
and tell us what you want to see a photo
of in this game and tell us also about
your favorite Pokemon games or favorite
pokemon episodes did you said you played
the cards first is that right I did I
collected the cards first nice did you
have a holographic charizard um I did I
still have it you still have I still
have it all sonata first editions oh
yeah whatever I don't even have one
about buying a first edition recently I
had lost my ancient Musa recently I
ordered one puff of like mayor ah oh my
god little punk I don't know what I was
about to call peachy um I ordered one
off of Amazon something I was like six
bucks my whole childhood that was the
most precious thing I could have
order okay i'm also going to take a
picture of the messed up one um yes i
still collect I mean not as intensely as
I used to of course but I still phone a
lot of the cards and i recently got the
radiant collection which is like a bunch
of hollows ooh and it's really nice
that's fun y'all dead hey I missed
kakuna that's fine we have lots of time
you know we're here for a while yeah we
do have a lot of time we're actually
we're it's 122 so we're halfway in
almost just about so we have just over a
half hour left to take more pictures of
Pokemon yeah yeah so let us know if
there's a specific Pokemon you want us
to find and I will get better at this I
just spoke I just want a Psyduck that is
all I want by end of the stream I always
here I love ghost pokemon to I it's so
weird to my favorite pokemon or Never my
favorite types like i love i love ghost
pokemon but my fault i guess music you
as it goes yeah Oh question on youtube
from dark mask how well does snap
control on the Wii U gamepad it's not
controlling as because I would like to
be the ID honest oh yeah it's probably a
little bit better on the n64 controller
back in the day maybe it's also because
I didn't change it the XY axis I don't
know if that's even an option I totally
forget but it is a little like a it's
not smooth and I have been playing a lot
of Pokemon mood and I'm you do unlock
stuff yeah the Polka finder camera
feature that's like putting on snap and
so that's a lot smoother and I have a
much easier time and it's got our old so
it's really weird to get used to this
and to go back to something from Brennan
said hit the last electro to open a new
map is that true hit the last electro
you like take a picture of it or we
don't have anything good about it yeah
is that him that's Hannah okay get for
the tip thanks for the hot tip thank you
guys on your way in this photo i'm
assuming yeah how do i I forgotten my
draining we've gotten all by terrific
so let's hope that we get a new map out
of this I hope someone said rare bird
are also on this map interesting well be
a rare birds interesting whatever air
birds what kind of rare birds do you
speak up at the opening or ending and so
I mean I were a pinning yeah we're at
the end so let's see what we've got I'll
skip Pikachu we have some peas we do we
do have some solid Pikachu's camera
check camera will check at that time of
course okay all right no he looks mad
yeah he is not happy does this okay if I
get an exploding like I'm just gonna try
yeah just try it see if anything happens
this is Cole oh we need apples to hit
the electrode oh wait I want passed out
but I'm not electabuzz oh my god Kyle
Splinter said we need apples to hit it
okay okay how do we obtain these apples
these mysterious apples one day and the
heart tech said it'll open the volcano
good to know thanks for the tips guys
it's been a while we have no not played
this in years I probably have not played
this in since like I was I have no idea
what however old I was maybe 2,000 I
probably haven't played since 2000 happy
have not played this in years zap doses
egg is in the tunnel said the heart tech
Wow okay y'all are on their probably hit
that was something that egg it's weird
because this came out after eggs were a
thing in the Pokemon well know before
because gold silver and crystal came out
after this game
he us after this kid come on um but
there's eggs in it yo Oh Oh Ellen triple
oh I suppose it is get it yes good thing
we submitted that one has the technique
oh man nailed it I'm becoming a real
professional I love it Electabuzz I saw
in Pokemon moon I cotton electa bottles
and then I treated it with an elector
Iser to get electivire and then I traded
that electivire on the global trade
system to get a togekiss what you have
to do that the crazy QR thing to get oh
weird um and then I use that togekiss to
chain breed a big move on to my eevee
like it was this whole process wow that
is really complex I have no that's so
good flex more power to you though I
like this yeah if you guys have any
questions about any Pokemon games or
Pokemon Sun and Moon ask Callie cuz she
has reviewed the game yeah i reviewed
sun and moon as well as Omega Ruby and
I'm Empire yeah she knows quite a bit so
if you need any tips and tricks ask her
some questions yeah or just slip top to
us about Pokemon in general we're over
on YouTube and twitch right now so let's
see what's going on Alyssa said another
good thing from 1999 sega dreamcast oh
yeah I didn't have one I didn't yeah I
didn't have one we had a Genesis yeah i
went from nes to Genesis to a super
nintendo n64 then all playstation after
that all plays like know there was like
a sega saturn in there somewhere i don't
know why okay what do you know we need
like a 1500 more points to do too
alright something you got that way
through I believe in you um but I will
do it okay Pikachu it's you and me man
now i'm kind of sad that I missed out on
the Dreamcast my bad oh my gosh um yeah
I yeah my console history is so weird I
jumped from uh oh like Sega to oops Sega
to Nintendo too
to Xbox like I was just all over the
place she's probably you're not supposed
to take a picture from behind right hmm
which is probably what Oh kakuna hakuna
I could do this I could do did you get
it I'm like rose in titanic go back so
how was your favorite a lola version
pokemon um Vulpix a little pecks is my
fav it's ice and ferry which are two
super cool types and really rare types
and it has it's actually that's i forgot
to mention for the person who asked what
my competitive team is that's also going
to be on there isn't a lowland ninetails
just for Aurora veil which is basically
reflecting light screen all in one um
and I just I love it so much it's that's
good move beautiful beautiful
reimagining of that Pokemon and I just
think it was really creative what about
you uh I just really want a dugtrio with
hair I don't have one yet it's called
Destiny's Child that's so perfect for
dancing it's so fab yes handsome and on
what you were into no it's it is
definitely hansen just the long blond
hair that's gotta be it King lo said if
Pokemon snap to was an adventure /
open-world game taking pictures how
would you guys feel about that this is
AUSA that sounds great I would run
around take pictures of Pokemon that
sounds fantastic I literally just want
to live in the Pokemon universe yeah my
uh a friend of mine recently texted me
and was like you know if you were in the
Pokemon universe she'd be like a
professor something and I was like
that's the nicest thing any old that is
a compliment and so I just want that
universe to be real in some fashion yeah
I feel like you would study them super
hard and you just know everything there
is to know about them so yeah you'd
probably be a professor Pokemon
photojournalists photo isthmus that's me
I would be the Pokemon photojournalist
photojournalism simulator to it I'm
really irritated that I can't catch a
picture yeah catch a picture nevermind
i'm not a photo I'll stick to Pokemon is
Alex wrote us at pokemon go is basically
pokemon snap to already far less yeah
that's at his good point i do take a lot
of photos in pokemon go or I did screen
screenshots I screenshots I wish that
there had been a Pokemon and me or poke
on refresh depending if you played X or
you had I wish there was a version of
that just interaction with the Pokemon
inside of me because I feel like that
are Josh in sentiment in Pokemon code
because I feel like that would have
enhanced my desire to that's a terrible
picture cookies my desire to that one's
better to catch a bunch of Pokemon oh
really good I good job Brittany Browder
look at how pressure with a it precious
baby this is this is at electrodes the
winner that's that's a ding yeah um what
was i I was gonna submit mommy giggling
I need to I need a diglett yeah just cuz
that's a new one or it yeah I always
haven't submitted yeah ok so we're
halfway through our stream if you're
just tuning in I'm chastity this is
Callie she's our new associate editor
and we're playing pokemon snap on the
wii u virtual console and we're hanging
out with our buddies over on youtube and
twitch right now talk about pokemon all
things pokemon in 1999 really is what
the theme of our chat is today Garrett
what your favorite 19 days memory is
speaking of kyle's winner once at 1999
was the year family guy aired oh nice
Wow that's been a while I on for a long
time yeah I didn't realize I mean I was
always a Simpsons kid like I would watch
the simpsons yeah like way too young and
so I never occurred to me like how just
how long some of the other animal issues
have been airing oh god this has been on
for a long time like oh yeah I mean it
was on
you know it was a short yeah it was a
but yeah yeah I just I wasn't allowed to
watch like south park or anything I
never think of South Park as big as long
run we're family guy yeah so yeah that's
crazy that is a long time mind blown you
know what's turning 20 this year what it
so we're going to talk about 99 anymore
Austin wow I just re-watched it holds up
really well it still makes me laugh it's
so dumb I love it oh but no no we it is
1999 because the spy who shagged me came
out in 1999 so there you go when I bring
it back that's what I'm here for the new
power couple hello oh yeah if you
haven't seen our really dumb snapchat
today go over snapchat and check out
gamespot com snapchat story where we
promote this live stream that you're
watching right now it's still funny
though so you can watch it after this
dream it'll be funny it was still be
funny I hope maybe not to you but
someone said over on YouTube you unlock
the food / bait at 24,000 points do we
have that many points yeah I don't know
but we just got pokemon food and then I
had to repeat the instructions a
thousand times on accident because yes i
would love to keep going thank you yay
we're gonna hit that electrode i missed
how to throw it but i'm sure i'll fish
freak out also he said to try throwing
it and an electrode yep to see what
happens let's see if we can unlock this
volcano this time around if we have
stuff to throw okay oau throat with a Oh
excellent drive to a proper oh yeah so
that's in it work they've one of your
would do have unlimited apples I think
so okay so then we have to throw an
apple at the very last electrode to get
the volcano according to our friends in
chat thank you so much for the tips yeah
thank you guys thank you guys for
knowing more about the game can we do
cuz we'll have not played this in a long
time and look it's been it's been a
minute I've played so many pokemon games
I can't even tell you like that I just I
got stuff I gotta do you know
okay i'm gonna try throwing it at this
one oh he doesn't like that oh I feel
bad i'm sorry baby ah i'm trying too
many things happens if i throw it at the
egg probably nothing it's probably
something he could you I got you thank
you just you know cuz ya you know it's
good why not ok I will get you Magikarp
I will find there you that was pretty
good i was ok i was pretty good i think
it could have been centered more but
considering the time that was a decent
biddable yeah um I'm not really trying
for like stardom here no we're just
trying to get the next map I just want
us I need to find my son have you seen
my son and you defend my son we should
have brought so I I have like this
little psyduck figure that chastity
course I duck so we would have don't
talk to me or my son ever again yes I
didn't know this was on the wii u so
toast man yet but today today as of
today so that is why we're playing it
yeah and i can get it right now for ten
dollhairs 10 buck 10 whole doll hairs
which is a seems a lot for an old game
but is pretty I really intend Oh does
what's the price on nostalgia or that
Apple appleton to the electrode ok it's
an apple how far can I throw an apple
you think not very far ok so close let
me get nice and close technically this
is just pokemon food it's not even oh I
wonder if I could overshoot sauce it no
I can't that worked right it's like on
his face you doesn't have to hit him
right in the face yeah oh yes we got him
come in club did we need a picture of it
oh I did not cuz clearly Oh pass away
wait that's so cool that's us that that
right there is a dress park shot he's
like
that is some real I think hovers yeah so
who I I'm just amazed that okay so that
one is king lo said just wondering are
you guys [ __ ] ready yes I don't know
what do you think all day all day if you
don't get that that's a reference to our
lovely snap story please check it out
over on snapchat over on the account
gamespot com we had a lot of fun this we
did we shot a nice little promo video oh
it exploded whoo yeah well done get in
those points we're gonna go to this
volcano we're gonna look for some cool
pokemon in there see what's going on I
just whatever i don't know uh he can
insult me all he wants me I wasn't
trying that's a secret if you were
trying to this making your feelings have
you ever done any Pokemon cosplay uh oh
have I I did a very casual misty once
yeah I am that'd be really cute yeah
such a cool mystique and then is when
why I had bangs and my hair was shorter
um and then I do really want to do an
Officer Jenny I know you didn't offer
surgery I did yes I did Officer Jenny
and my best friend Jen was Nurse Joy so
we were quite the pair yeah and I also
did a had a snorlax dress nothing fancy
it was a snorlax dress and sweet dish oh
there's so many of them center that
Center it I going hahahaha this little
majestic you see that video of the guy
who gets the shiny ponyta yes doing rng
manipulation Annie ponyta it was that
was what them yes oh it's beautiful but
but but I'm not gonna submit that one
but I just fall pics but I think vulpix
is one of my full pigs but I love okay
used to be my favorite I guess Evie is
kind of ladies better I stock answer but
I really do love babies so much better
not a contest they're both cute and I
will cuddle them both
yep everyone's welcoming everyone is
looking up you know what I don't like
what more I hate magmar what is magmar
trying to be it is a duck what is that
like look at it but hey what is it yes
Charmander my boy did I actually get a
boy Charmander gosh yeah it's two boys
are matter now all I could think of is
that sad episode of him on the rock I
guess I'm guessing this is Moltres oh
did i do want to like you look yes ah so
beautiful yes I the better I'm a Pokemon
master it's so beautiful we did it oh
and now i'm just looking at the chat
that Moltres on this map yeah we found
it we found it I got it I'll did that
for you they all came back that's for
you guys for you guys we found it for
you I don't know if you've ever played
banjo tooie but this reminds me of this
level in banjo tooie where it's like
fire and ice mmm cuz of this like glue
whatever this blue is rare I forget what
it's called now but deep cuts I'm so
proud of myself oh oh hey [ __ ] huh oh
hey bud it when we get his face get his
face yes yes I didn't center that one
look I got his face speaking of austin
powers we should just be like you're
attacking yes yes no no oh my god the
90s are back you know why should I
should have worn my choker one of my
chokers yeah a bunch of joke you have a
cool Sailor Moon choker I have yeah that
I envy it's very nice yeah I have one of
those tattoo ones there's like an
original stretchy ones yet it for like
99 cents yep let's see dem boys over and
twitching YouTube right now oh hey Chris
waters Chris waters is hanging out over
onto which hey what's up bud which I
think that's better let's see what's up
Chris look at it I want to see an
alakazam said alyssa will try it's you
or bet we'll do our best for you I think
this is I'm just going to submit this
cuz I think it's a beautiful food it's
like Instagram
I think I have a better one of Magdalene
chris said beam that dude into the love
way I need some help so this is not the
best one all right what's better oops
what is best Moltres yeah the gun or
this wings open his face isn't in it
this one is all feet yeah it is all feet
alright so more centered yeah I don't
know I show that middle one let me see
them on the one nah no all right yeah
one with wings open this that wouldn't
be perfect if it was centered there we
go that's let's try that one uh this is
where photo experts stupid Dullahan dumb
duck with the butt on its head so much
just save us ooh profile view okay
that's fine let's hit him into the lava
next time around hit magma riddle no no
charizard charizard Charmeleon because
someone said if he toss in the lobby
becomes jars i don't know if he's
telling the truth you know I don't know
if he's telling the truth but I feel
like that's not how I don't know if
that's how that works I don't think I'll
tell evolution works but imagine if
that's how it works in pokemon snap now
we have to try just dunk them we just
have to trach kit don't get dunked I
know this is backwards I just love this
I just full pics but full pigs but I'm
sorry I just like it yes sir oh oh can
we talk about how Professor Oak's cousin
is in sun and moon yeah let's talk about
him i miss safe uh and he's all like a
pokemon and he just kind of gives you
tips yeah he was a professor Kakui who
can't close his shirt he can't that man
cannot okay close the shirt a game freak
like just made progressively younger
yeah more svelte posso spelt because
everyone was really into sycamore from
why yeah I'll get the short our Guetta
and uh oh my friend leo is on the twitch
hi leo thanks for watching this is what
is what us sitting next to each other is
like to we're like this ya know it's
just like constant giggling or nothing
most usually pokemon pokemon I'm gonna
try just totally just beyond everyone
into the love knocking everyone has
knock everyone with apples into the lava
guys oh oh I'm sorry I feel me now we're
just beating him in the head rapidash 20
Kyle also said knock Charmeleon into the
lava with the apple okay all right oh oh
my god Oh looks like my oh yeah you did
beautiful I wish that was wait give that
one Oh give another one an apple and go
eat it make it cute this Lo oh did you
get that I do it I think oh my god I
just love it i'm taking pictures just
because i think they're so cute Oh even
though they're terrible pictures and
we'll get no point christendom Iran Vega
said what's your favorite pokemon game I
think we mentioned them earlier but like
our most beloved ones that are dear to
our heart mine is yellow Callie said
hers was crystal yeah but just in
general oh that's a tough one Oh what
that's oh my god what are you guys doing
what what are they doing I came to beam
you oh no I'm not yeah I'm gonna do this
again see [ __ ] them Jen's active uh we
got to go back to get Zapdos huh we have
to go back good to go go that was fine I
already got one okay screw you man swag
massa do you play super smash brothers
uh sometimes like casually once in a
while um I'm a lot better at other
fighting games I prefer Street Fighter
and Tekken and
Mortal Kombat and NBC but yeah super in
defining is I am but yet smash brothers
I'm is the one I'm the worst ass I I
will admit that so hit him hit him a try
I gonna try to do this I put so many
hours in the melee and I mein bomb a
light switch people made fun of me for
until they Oh hit this boy hit this go
ahead them in the hit of the law I into
the traffic get it oh my god yeah I've
never been more proud of you I just
remembered why this game rule I knew it
I knew it in my soul I see that that was
the moment I remember what this did you
guys on YouTube and twitch see that you
see that beautiful charizard have you
ever seen anything so beautiful I like I
don't think I've ever seen a creature
more majestic look at that huh serving
of my love takes my breath away king
Louis said are you guys getting intend
to switch yeah probably yeah that thing
is a portable I could play it anywhere
well I definitely just want to get it so
I could play that new Zelda yeah listen
I i will buy Skyrim anytime I can so I'm
excited for another prospect another
plates i can play Skyrim ah but yet I
mean I'm totally joking us I mean I will
buy skype uh okay which way to get from
sky okay Nintendo's was for spend I'm
talking I'm really excited for Zelda and
really excited to see what they do going
forward cuz I know Nintendo's sort of
about trying things and experiment you
experimentation yeah okay let's do this
let's do it Chris waters gave us props
he said nicely done GG thank you beaned
him
the true 1999 way I think in 1989 a kid
in my class got hit by a rock oh my god
Wow whole lecture evaluations Torah
yikes so are we getting dark in 1999
some two kids that were skateboarding I
hit by a train at my school and I was
like oh my god okay they like think
they're okay yeah they were okay like it
it barely hit them like it didn't hit
them head-on it's just like caress them
wow that was enough to send them to like
just Whittle yeah tell us your worst
1999 memory is over on YouTube and
twitch those are outer it's for best we
would have to hear your bestest oh yeah
my favorite song of 1999 was probably
genie in a bottle listen about a good
song or chores are to explore I want it
that way I guess I wanted that weighs
more I wanted that I / Stronach yeah I
think I listen to a lot it when did
aaron carter starting um probably like
2000 2001 okay that I'm yeah I'm cuz he
was much younger he's a little baby does
anyone know how to unlock the next
course actually how do we get Zapdos
should I try to get zapped us yeah what
in volcano yeah how do I know zapdos
isn't Oh tunnel oh yeah there's an egg
there so maybe do we throw in it I threw
an apple at it um I don't know yeah oh
you guys know over and chat let us know
how to get that zapdos if you know
really quickly I'm just gonna go through
this again four points uh I forgot the
other the other obvious thing force
which is so obvious that i forgot to
mention it is the rumored pokemon stars
what is that which is really more
rumored to be I mean there's been a lot
of talk about it and we don't know a lot
but uh to be on oh I feel bad tippy on
switch and basically be a third you know
in the style Pokemon where there's a
third you know adventure that comes out
later um and it's supposed to be
enhanced I'm really hoping it has a move
tutor
my very selfish selfish thing that i was
there i just left because nick made a
bad pun and twitch chat he said those
Charizard photos are fire it's lit stop
stop it now yeah Pokemon stars if that
doesn't do the thing is Pokemon stars
sounds good to me I will play that you
need to you need the pester ball for
zapdos is what the heart text said wow
the heart tag is like an expert at
pokemon snap yeah thanks for all the
tips yeah thank you thank you um if you
choose Italy obviously this is Pokemon
to that look at this little baby we're
taking pictures of these beautiful
babies all over the place we're throwing
apples at pokemon and getting as you do
into lava making them evolve making them
hatch taking pictures this is on the wii
u it's on the Virtual Console as of
today and that's why we're playing it
it's not just out of nowhere we love
Pokemon so that is possible but look at
these boys fight oh my god pretty cool
okay it comes back yes flying around who
knows having a good time he's flying
around whoa what it's Miranda sorry I
just got really excited because our
buddy Miranda from IGN is now in the
twitch chat what's up what is up oh it's
a stuff we little party we're having
over on chat we being some boys we be in
some point of being this boy again we
have to do this for Miranda do it right
former this is for Miranda yes Miranda
this for you we'll try to get a good
photo oh look at our boy our sweet boy
our sweet boy I'm sorry greater
abandoned you evolution works so much
more differently in pokemon snap all you
have to do is throw things into fire you
know what as Charles Darwin one
uh let's see someone said throw some
apples in that volcano in the beginning
with the purple smoke okay I was gonna
do I was gonna ask about the purple
smoke ya feel like oh it's so precious
angelic Bobby I feel like the purple
smoke it has something going on um this
is myranda's messages keep getting
censored on twitch so I'm just assuming
she's cursing a sound it just says
message deleted message to it i think is
she's just using him emotes moobot hate
spam that's what gyuki right said and it
o said I thought you guys killed him now
oh we just wanted him to evolve yeah
never kill a poke I would never think to
just kill him and make him a ball I mean
I make fire mm-hmm I wouldn't kill one
fighting magmar oh really oh my god 800
points how's the size how's the boat it
looks hot yeah get it we're in a volcano
I love all of these fire pants Oh
Miranda said she said hearts and my love
was rejected oh no we will never reject
your love thank you thank you so much if
I do better Chris waters had all right
y'all catch you later happy Pokemon
catch get it
hi Chris Chris used to have my job hello
and then you usurped him no he went to
soar like an eagle we need to take two
more pictures what alright will do this
for you professor oak there's just
something about professor oak that I
trust you know yeah I mean he has straw
look up to him he does his eyebrow game
is pretty strong like that boy where he
keeps him tweezed he keeps him tweeze he
fills him in you know he went to
anastacio ok nope I missed one oh fun oh
the work anything we did it went in it
earth maybe not please do we have pester
balls yet no am I yet I think we get
them after two pictures which I should
probably start taking in a second yes
let's take some pictures novoflex over
here love me love us love us Vulpix hey
you will they fight or well they just
like try to both eat the apple I don't
know
oh no they won't fight how do you get
nine tails I wonder to him to kill 10
that's on sad throw it in the fire see
if it grows I deny is there water here
song so thrown up into the water to get
a magic part we saw Magikarp earlier
there's water that's when I was saying
it looked like this Bansha to anything
yes that was Cameron over on YouTube
thank you thank you everyone's so
helpful y'all are so nice give them boys
an apple I did okay I think if
Charmander beats magmar to it he evolves
or something that's what I'm lesson oh
there you are friend hey buddy god I
love trying mater so much oh my god did
you hear you I want to see you guys
fight about how I pic I love it i also
love it someone say you can make a
Charmander evolved into Charmeleon by
getting magmar to fight over an apple
that happened right yeah yeah we did
that we on that thank you
do it I did it where you at no be like
this one more oh that is aa trig it yep
yep got it thank you Oh be that boy I
got heated that boy comin in touch with
the Apple Miranda said I hate all the
magmar in this level yeah weird we were
making fun of them earlier cuz we just
don't like them cuz magmar thugs with
but face and it's duck bit like what are
you what are you trying to be I don't
know who are you do re r us to find
yourself magmar okay let's see we got
enough points I think this how do we get
the next stage we had two points was a
point okay no it was number of pictures
taken this is probably the best one of
whole pics i have full gym boy um this
is the same as before except with more
fire I love this okay mm-hmm let me see
if I have better box 120 said those
little magma pools can get growlithe and
arc 9 later with pester walls don't we
just need those festivals them I think
we might unlock them after this I feel
like that's something happening what's
new this time take a look at our
beautiful photos Professor Oak oh I can
hold my dinner on good my technique is
better on the improvement oh well I got
10 more points buddy okay this whole
place is gonna really improve oh no it's
not
as I said Wow he liked it I'm gonna save
the one that you like to see if this is
better than fighting McGuire for so we
have roughly five minutes left in this
stream but we might stay a little bit
longer if we open up a new course just
to show you guys that but if we don't
then we'll cut it off BAM yeah we will
bounce but we are playing pokemon snap
on the wii u virtual console I'm chasidy
that's Callie we poke at kids she's our
new Pokemon expert here at gamespot also
an associate editor let's go in your
card Pokemon X bar comma associate
editor wait what the heck oh my gosh did
he mean two more pokemon like like as in
Pokemon cheese mmm go back in I feel
like there's ones i missed or something
what if I go yeah go back to the earlier
ones I use apples I hit app yeah I use
it to get a better photo that's it how
can you get two more pokemon in the
levels we already have let us know
experts on youtube please you guys are
so much better at this what happens if i
hit good oh no come back to me the joker
said this game takes me back us too
clearly not far back enough yeah I can't
remember I can't remember what I was
doing in 99 like guys going to school
being a dumb kid being a kid yeah hmm oh
my gosh stop moving yeah we take
pictures of two new Pokemon so we need
yeah we did choose a new stage we just
need to find two different pokemon yeah
so fret not we have not yeah I'm
goodness i think Snorlax I mean pester
ball might be the way to wake up Snorlax
but I'm gonna go ahead and try an apple
it's probably pestered ball worth a shot
might as well yeah there's also oh come
down to me love me
and there's also a full of fit jiggly
ball Furcal Faria damn you girl said
Lapras endless level in the ocean oh
cool glad we re food pass the ocean
unless I just did we get kangaskhan
already we did right yes yes beach with
the Apple oh I might have gotten the
Lapras that I'm not sure anything in
those flowers well yeah apparently but
someone's there someone's in the grass
oh there's that leprous there's that boy
that boy wonder yes oh my god don't do
ya hello yeah so any flowers and stuff
we should throw apples into I didn't
even know stop yeah yes Cian a snail did
got it okay do already have Oh lapis are
you gonna come closer you punk I mean
was over there bein someone said there
was a site they're behind us behind us
probably we must know yeah I mean that's
totally in the grass whereas coming up
cuz they're a more elaborate a said okay
site there in the grass but need pester
balls boo we don't have them yet oh did
they just oh my god Oh for me out well
mouth was trying to eat them so he had
it coming yeah to be fair yeah I feel
like I think we only got one I don't
think laughs first register no too far I
think it might've been too far but we'll
see ya Game Freak said to wake up
Snorlax need a flute makes sense that is
half made could never be sure make sense
this game has lots of different config
yeah like throwing people into fire not
people with Pokemon and making them
evolve
if you take pictures of the Lapras it
gets closer after each one okay okay
we're just gonna I this is not going to
get any points but it does register
Pokemon I'm gonna submit this because
it's like it okay cool cool it will
hustle will get Bella yes let's try well
we have a minute left in the stream but
should we just try we should do we
should do it I'm going we owe it to our
friends over and chat who have helped us
get this far they just want to see you
succeed and we want to succeed for them
we really appreciate all the help yes
thank you for helping us so we'll hang
out with you guys for just a wee bit
longer so we can hopefully get the one
we need one more left just one more we
need one more Pokemon to move on Lapras
was always one of my favorites actually
okay I'm not gonna take pictures of
anything but Lapras yeah I should go for
it this is what we doin we out here
actually I will probably tracker that
scyther just because Miranda said you
can do it oh ok where are you my love
lead Pikachu to the surfboard with
apples where is the surfboard wait this
is surfboard Oh força go cook come back
thanks Jason thank you okay I saw the
Lapras I snapped up there oh yes oh yay
got you got you yes you're mine oh yeah
we did it okay just Pikachu surf someone
asked me that we don't have time to try
it but I would lay out so we won't be
able to wake up the snorlax just yet no
but he's there I was throwing flowers
just
I like now some pictures can we talk
about a low amount nails for a sec yeah
like purple and like water what's in
yeah let's find out there must be a
scyther somewhere something who is here
who's cutting up all that grass is it's
like that imagine come on you could do
it but should the spam the apples okay I
guess maybe I'm you might need a pester
ball or so oh hey hey you might need
something other than that yeah who wants
apples we got unlimited apples as
Apple's everywhere it's making it rain a
perf real you have fun now we go lap for
something okay okay yeah yeah we just
coast now look at these boys I love that
what does that Rolie Polie boys yeah
that's a good chance a good photo very
nice it's something to do that turn
around and look at me yeah oh wait
kangaskhan with you oh okay I guess we
didn't register kangaskhan okay well
then we got two new ones i guess this i
only took photos for time yep well so
the but don't count but still yeah I
feel like oh oh my god oh my god land I
feel like there's something in there
nothing happens oh good job we did it we
did it ok feel so before we leave you
guys today we will take a look at these
photos and open up the next level and
then it'll be up to you will see 10 you
say no will have to go soon yeah where's
my lap
counted in the disk very nice very nice
that's why I love this picture chancy
that's good that is good one kangas gone
looking real mad at me get away from my
check guys do it over on youtube and
twitch who do you want to see in this
last level or who you hope to see
because we can't make any promises one
more level so we have one more level
going as quickly as again yeah yeah
that's a really good chance e that's a
good kangaskhan mamas man okay come on
yeah wait Britney oh speaking of which
we named it Brittany yes of the 90s Todd
snap is not a really good name forever
let's do it yeah so this will be the
very last level we're playing for you
guys but if you want to play yourselves
you can do that today on your wii u by
getting it for virtual console it's
pokemon snap yeah come down here poliwag
happens video back is that a Bulbasaur
yeah hello boy into the log can you
throw it in yes this is so reward oh oh
my god squirrel that probably get do it
again pull us so good oh I'm so proud of
you pull the store there's a good jump
good boy such them hear me another
Bulbasaur I probably turned then what's
all about ah slowpoke is one of my top
five favorite Pokemon loves I love oh
look at him I named my stuff Ursula hit
him again hit him again I want him to
look at us look at me look look at me so
yes I thousand years yes oh that's the
shelter oh wait if we can get weak
probably evolved it in SLO brew we did
some
special probably look if like he did
this Taylor therapy yeah we got a
shoulder huh um could he get him to walk
over there oh yeah get him to walk over
here come here buddy you're so slow your
buddy come on he's a slow bro yep yep
yes you're gonna happen it's happening
yeah do it come on do it yes we did a
boy I love slowbro oh this is there's
nothing better unless you find a Psyduck
Metapod I feel like site like will
probably be around here somewhere yeah
are you gonna register or not well there
we go wait wait on hold your hold up
phone my son's here oh hello be oh my
sweet beautiful son please feed him he's
so hungry oh he's Lisa please second guy
I love side up so much she really he is
one of my favorite Jags in the whole
world yes he has sitex socks I do Oh
cluster oyster his long as one of those
in our wait yep who's there hit the
button I'm trading hate to button oh
come out it's a what no just come out
who are you love us all right we tried
it's okay like this whole thing is was a
success because we found side on so i'm
satisfied with our progress today hey
pika pika okay there I don't want to get
this shelter before things are over but
I don't know
what's going on oh good job we did it
guys that was a lot of Pokemon I was a
lot of Pokemon they good places to thank
you for joining us everyone I'm Shasta
you can follow me on twitter at chastity
underscore v i'm callie you can find me
on twitter at aikido chico i NK y te ji
kk o just look for Callie's leg it'll
come up and we will see you next time
and for all things Pokemon stick with
gamespot bye